mmm jello it's jiggly all-american and
your parents may have grown up eating it
in salad form where did this beautiful
gelatin and a box come from gelatin
based desserts have been around since at
least in the 1500s but they used to only
be available to the rich who had
servants with lots of time to boil vats
of animal bones and other parts down to
gelatin it wasn't until 1845 that an
inventor named Peter Cooper came up with
a recipe for powdered gelatin in 1895 he
sold the recipe to pearl and Mae weights
who decided to branch out from their
failing cough syrup and laxative
business and get into food adding sugar
and fruit flavoring to the gelatin Mae
came up with the name we all know so
well jell-o but the couple eventually
sold the product to this guy in the
early 1900s jello was marketed to
Americans as a way to enjoy a dish
normally reserved for the wealthy
instant jello made it quick easy and
affordable for the average housewife to
make beautiful and interesting looking
molded salads it became so
quintessentially American that new
immigrants were given packets of jell-o
when they arrived at Ellis Island and
just like other advertisements of the
era some of those ads were downright
racist jello got another boost after
World War 2 when electricity and
refrigeration spread to the most rural
parts of the US bringing with it a huge
push for processed and convenience food
the 50s and 60s were the heyday of
molded salads consisting of fruits
vegetables fish and meat yes meat
suspended in jello yeah it's pretty
girls these jello concoctions apparently
helped make solid appeal to America's
sweet tooth since the late 1970s
jell-o's advertising campaigns have been
more about kid-friendly fun now we can
eat jell-o gelatin with our bare hands
Matt Glenn Bill Cosby was still
considered a wholesome family man and we
can't forget to mention Utah where gelas
been the official state snack since 2001
today jell-o is still a staple at
potluck dinner tables and college
parties hmm jiggle it